rich white women rich white women
because you are white
if you are white and have ever
accomplished anything in your life
it is not due to your hard work it is
due to the privilege of your white skin
i don't want to just hire four white
people you know what i mean
maybe two white and two of color
something like that
dear white people
this is what we want you to do
it's time to acknowledge that the work
of anti-racism is white people's work
hello thank you for signing up to
participate in the white accountability
group for staff and faculty
whiteness can be hard for white people
to acknowledge and the
self-victimization of white people is
extremely harmful for black people and
people of color
it is our responsibility
especially those of us who are white to
do better
to do more
these are just a few of the many things
i heard while i was working as a staff
member at smith college
are you
jeff the right person
or are you jody's show
well i used to think i was just jody
shaw
and then i started working at smith and
i started
to think of myself more and more as a
white person
[Music]
hi it's jody
i
no longer work in the department of
residence life in the division of
student affairs at smith college
jody is a very courageous woman
it was an agonizing
decision
you cannot subject people
to trainings where you're telling them
that they are bad or shaming them
rather
[Music]
because they don't do something you
expect them to do based upon their skin
color jody shaw had the courage
it was essentially a decision between
comfort
or freedom
[Music]
and i chose freedom obviously she had
the courage she has two children
it was her job she graduated from there
i chose to fight
[Music]
a friday afternoon
i stepped off a cliff
it's
hard to watch an institution
say all these things like smith has said
for years about empowering women and
doing this and doing that and then watch
them
in action
and find out
that a lot of it is just talk
i
retained the right to file a legal claim
in a u.s court of law against smith
college and that's what i intend to do
[Music]
[Music]
jack and jill
came tumbling down that
[Music]
he let go of her hand
that is something i will
never
understand
who is jody shaw
well
i
i'm gonna start what i grew up mostly in
new england
my parents moved around a lot
and then i
went to smith college
i was on the swim team
which i loved
i was all-american my sophomore year
i graduated with a degree in
anthropology
i started a creative writing program in
new mexico new mexico state and while i
was there i discovered music
writing to music is just feels so much
more immediate and compelling and
engaging than just writing on a page
so i dropped out
and i
moved back east and i ended up in new
york city in right before the twin
towers fell
i lived kind of a very
for lack of a better word very bohemian
life very hand to mouth i
worked various day jobs
[Music]
i performed on the subway for many years
it was it was one of the most spiritual
experiences of my life
and they only put a dollar in your
hat if they like your music it's very
honest
so i had i had children and i had whoa i
had twins surprise
i got married
i moved to a very different part of
brooklyn
and then when i was getting divorced
i talked to my ex about moving back to
northampton but let's move back to
northampton we we're getting divorced we
can't afford to live in the same
neighborhood in new york city
when i was a student at smith college i
remember northampton just being this
like
magical place super liberal and i was a
card-carrying member of the socialist
party in my early 20s
and i was hired as an engagement
librarian for my ability to creatively
engage and draw in students and get them
to use the library more
i arrived with a whole lifetime a whole
history and i was not in the habit of
making assumptions about people and
when i arrived
to smith college i found that that's
exactly what they wanted me to do
this is the role you're supposed to play
as a white person and this is the role
that other people are going to play that
are not white people and this is how
you're supposed to interact and this is
what you're supposed to say and do
it didn't feel right it didn't ring true
to me but i thought
i doubted myself i did go along with it
then this happened
a woman from new york city says she was
racially profiled while eating her lunch
an employee calling police on a black
student because she seemed quote out of
place amu kanote is a rising sophomore
at smith college she was reading in the
dining hall of the tyler house dorm the
man asked me we were wondering why
you're here i don't even feel safe
i'm doing this not only for me but for
my family for my ancestors what do you
want to happen now
i want the identity of the caller
released i want a public apology from
that caller and i want them fired
[Music]
sorry i actually sent an email to a
black colleague who had left the college
saying you know isn't this terrible and
i didn't know any of the facts i just
took the college's word for it
and then a month later
[Music]
what happened to me was i was a
temporary librarian so and i had been
tasked with creating a highly memorable
and engaging orientation for first
incoming first-year students to the
college
this was the last day of orientations
the person who gave me the venue said in
reality most students by then are
exhausted and they don't want to go to
any more orientations but if you do
something wild and crazy i promise you i
will get the students in there and i
thought well
it's obvious
i'll do a wrap
[Applause]
naturally i saw this as my opportunity
to really shine i was actually up for a
permanent job which would have been
meant a lot of security for my family
a week before i was supposed to do this
performance and this orientation for 600
students and you can imagine all the
work that goes into something like that
my supervisor came into my office and he
said given the incidents of july 31 2018
we can't do the rap
and i was like well why what do you mean
and he said because you're white
i've started to
connect the dots with this july 31 2018
incident what i saw after that incident
was the college immediately jumping to
the conclusion that this had been a
racial incident so what actually
happened
here is the rest of the story
is that this took place during the
summer
which is a time when
obviously normal academic classes are
not in session smith college has summer
programs all summer long and a lot of
and they're housed in the dormitories
and that house is tyler house and they
were expecting an influ of
very young dance student
staff who were working in that
particular dining hall because they were
working
around kids had all had to have
background checks umu was supposed to be
eating at lamont house which was across
campus and i understand why she didn't
because it was more convenient
where she was at the time to go into
tyler dining room
so we were always told
when you're working in the dorms if you
see something say something
and if it's a stranger
don't approach the stranger call campus
police because
you know they can come up and figure it
out
jackie blair happened to be working in
that dining hall at the time and said
something
oh i didn't know you were in this
program and the student said just
flashed her her student id jack is just
like okay fine whatever and allow the
student to stay and in walks a custodian
and the custodian's glancing around
because his job is to close up the house
for the day i knew this guy i'd worked
with him for 30 years and he's the most
innocuous
nicest
guy
what he sees through these double doors
obscured by a giant teddy bear is a pair
of legs on the couch so the custodian
called campus police who are unarmed
hi how are you doing good how are you
wondering why you were here oh i was
eating lunch i'm working the summer
program so i was just relaxing all my
time
yeah are you
with one of the song programs yeah i'm
actually a ta okay so that's what it was
all right you just said keep on the
doorway
yeah i i
it's okay it's just like kind of stuff
like this happens way too often where
people just feel like threatened he
allowed her to stay
he's like no problem just
everything's cool and he left and then
the student posted it that evening to
her facebook page
the facebook post went viral
the administration president mccartney
they immediately assumed guilt on
the employee's part
which meant that they let a 19 year old
student
wreak havoc
to me that meant that
union staff were
valueless
that they were disposable
kathy mccartney came in as the free
speech president she was going to come
in and champion free speech
very shortly after that there was an
incident where
somebody was talking about black lives
matter and kathy got up and said all
lives matter
very innocently
said this and she got
lambasted for this she was like i'm very
sorry
we need to talk about
systemic racism
there's a level of cowardice involved
she um she was terrified
of
being called
a racist
president mccartney has been making what
six hundred thousand dollars or
something a year
living in a mansion that was that's paid
for
she probably spent three million dollars
having the house redone inside to her
specifications and the gardens redone
i don't think she has a good moral
compass
i don't think she gives a [ __ ]
except about herself the first time i
met her
the first thing i thought of was the
word avaricious
[Music]
and i think i was right
three weeks later
the student was determined to find out
who had called campus police on her and
so she went through the staff directory
and found
two individuals and posted them to her
facebook page and said these are the two
people who called campus policy and that
facebook post went went viral
i i'm the infamous
employee who was not on campus during
this
incident of july i believe 31st
2018.
i was at home here having lunch
when the incident happened
so it's amazing how much trouble i got
in
it was a normal day like any other
getting ready for school opening
and i got paged and it was
the director of our department at the
time but diane bonoy
we sat down she told me that i was put
out there as
the racist who called
the police on the student
oh
okay because i knew it wasn't me
after that a few few of my co-workers
came in and
joking around
with me saying what did you do what did
you do
holding the union president had
printouts of her facebook page
with
my picture
jackie blair's picture calling us racist
i knew then things were serious i have
an impression that
if you work as a custodian
or a dining room assistant or you're in
a union
and you're actually wearing a blue
uniform
somehow that means that you are
uneducated
and
lower class
and therefore you're more apt to be
racist
by the time i got
home
my anxiety was off the charts
i have a family i have a house i have a
mortgage and i was making 40 000 a year
the stress on my wife was
unreal stress on our relationship was
unreal
there was some bad times
we're the fall guys
we're expendable
human resources
if they post a job they'll have 300
applications the next day
people out there
they're dying to get into the college to
work they know that so what i have to
say or if whatever
i'm expendable
northampton
[Music]
that i grew up in
was
it was generational
people definitely put people first
my father was in politics local politics
and
it was all about
your neighbor
[Music]
he he went into it with
wanting to help people and you were able
actually to help people
and unfortunately through the years
it changed
i always thought i would call it home
i don't anymore
and i don't believe i ever will
because of
what happened at smith college the
college never came out and publicly
apologized to these staff members we're
sorry that we continued to push this as
a racial incident when it wasn't and
we're sorry that you were
collateral in that the person who made
these
accusations
that she understands
[Music]
what she said her words
did this
her
not thinking about her words
did this
and there was just no
nothing from smith nothing
that's why it goes back to your
what i said earlier you just a number
you're just a number
[Music]
july 31st 2018 it changed the campus
one now has in the back of their mind if
i mess this up or if i say the wrong
thing or if i just happen to be in the
wrong place at the wrong time what i saw
happen to those people can happen to me
because it's not real power it's a fear
power and once
a student sees that an entire college
administration will turn cartwheels to
appease them do you think they're going
to stop
jody was being asked to
do things she was uncomfortable with at
work
they had some kind of a retreat
explaining white privilege and how that
affects you and the way you treat other
people
you know what you need
what are these
white privilege classes
helps you see the world the way we do
i was up for a permanent position so i
was like i don't want to say anything
like if i say i should report this but
maybe i shouldn't maybe it means i'm
racist and if i do i won't get a job and
so my solution to that was simply to
exit
the situation and i thought
if i leave the academic part of smith
and go to the non-academic the residence
life that surely
this all of this talk about race and
white privilege and all that stuff like
surely i will go below the radar
but i was wrong
i was told in the res life department
that i had to consider color in dealing
with students and colleagues
but nobody ever told me what that meant
what does that mean to consider color
part of my job was helping students get
room changes based on accommodate room
accommodations based on a disability so
this student had service dog and
training she's a white student and
there was a black student who lived in
the room near her who said that the the
dog was making a lot of noise and
bothering her i didn't know the skin
colors of the students at first
the student with the service dog she'd
done all this
interpersonal conflict resolution these
attempts at resolving it she had all
this documentation about all these
things she had done with the dog
i'd received no information from the
other student
and then i received
something from another student in the
house who
sent a video of the student who's airing
about the dog banging on the floor even
when the dog was not present
i talked with one of my supervisors and
the suggestion was let's offer a room
change to the student who has a problem
with the noise
seems simple right
then
the skin colors were determined it was
we found out what the skin colors were
and then there was a complete switch
like uh oh no let's not do that let's
offer the room change to the student
with the dog
[Music]
it felt so wrong because here's smith
talking about you know anti-racism and
all these uh
fighting systemic racism and
it was they were asking me to
participate in behavior that
was literally racist i i was looking at
two people's skin color and you're
supposed to take x action based on
because this person's white and this
person's black and
it really bothered me that i just didn't
want to be any part of this
[Music]
and when i saw the police officer who
had responded to the call when i saw him
get terminated
for a
unrelated incident
i saw a newly hired police chief
parted from the college
the college stated was amicable
but after seeing what happened where the
students posted his twitter feed
everywhere on campus and i also accused
him of being racist and then suddenly he
was just gone i started seeing things i
saw demands posted on my office door we
will come to every office
and every person if necessary to make
you feel our pain
now that
i think some people would listen to look
at that and say ah it's just students
like what are they really going to do
but against this backdrop where we have
already seen
this what happens when a student makes
an allegation even if unfounded where
you are literally guilt and guilty until
proven innocent and even still guilty
after that
or i'm going to take them seriously
because i've learned that the college
does not stand behind its staff i
finally filed my complaint it took me
hours and hours and hours to complete
this took me months and i
finally submitted it and then george
floyd died
and the college went into
uber hyperdrive after that and then i'm
told any refusal or
discomfort in discussing my race as a
white person at work is a quote power
play and i'm thinking to myself oh my
god what do i do
do i sit there and say nothing after i
filed this complaint and made clear and
now my silence is even more
interpreted even more as an act of
aggression or hostility they make you
feel like you're going crazy because
they make you feel like you have to
conform to their
philosophies and their narratives and if
you don't then there's something wrong
with you
um when actually
the all the a lot of the employees
there's nothing wrong with them except
they're in terror of losing their jobs
so
how the hell can so many smart people be
so stooped
[Music]
i filed an 80 page complaint
and
the college conducted what was in my
opinion a
highly disingenuous investigation
and issued a
a three letter
a three page response saying that my
allegations are unfounded so so
umu filed a face she she filed she
posted a made a facebook post and the
college responded with a
70-plus page investigation
so i did i sent out a few hail mary
emails and when those went those were
not responded to
i decided to
make
the first video
i'm white
and that really shouldn't be relevant
but my employer has made it clear over
and over and over again
that not only is it relevant but it's
possibly
one of the most important
or if not the most important feature of
me as a human
am i
at peace with my decision to speak out
is what you're asking
yes
yes i there are things i
probably would have done differently of
course looking back
i did not feel i had a choice i did feel
like if i continued
to not speak out and
along that path
the psychic pain of doing so would be
greater than the cost of speaking out
the
the cost of there has been a cost of
speaking out but
my
my reward is that i have
i'm now in contact with hundreds of
people who
feel the same way
and certainly the lawsuit that's very
important because if nobody challenges
this in court
then it kind of becomes acceptable so
i'm hoping my case is successful or one
of the other cases that are coming up
will be successful and set a precedent
you can't expect a material reward
when you're undergoing a spiritual quest
when you
undergo a spiritual quest the rewards
are not going to be material
and so
there is a lot of material fallout but
in the end
what's inside is what's most precious to
me and that's what i'm
seeking to preserve my integrity and my
morals
and those things are far more valuable
than
any material fallout i could suffer
so
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry because this
i believe the individual
miss kanute
doesn't understand
what she did
i'm sorry that the college doesn't
understand
what
their training's doing or what their
policies are doing
and i really wish they would
stand up for the people
that work for them
because those
first days of class wouldn't happen
without us
those those special events wouldn't
happen without us
those
those
cold cold winter mornings
4 a.m with a shovel in your hand
so they could all get to their office or
get to class
during a snowstorm
that was us nobody else so they need to
have a little more compassion
and a little less politically correct
i pray for jody
tracy
jackie
and the others
i know i'll be okay
i have the best support system here
um
but it hasn't been easy
i want president mccartney to see this
because i want her to know
we are human